we human beings enter the world full of
possibility
who will we become how will we affect
the world how will the world affect us
one thing is sure we will interact with
the world with other people the fetus
begins to develop an auditory system at
seventeen to nineteen weeks an infant
can make eye contact at one to two
months and we arrived with a special
gift a brain designed for social
interactions communication and we are
not alone other species are also social
they form groups they care for each
other they work together and other
species also have cognitive skills they
communicate
the evolution of other species as well
as humans may have been driven by social
interaction and the ability to solve
problems and create solutions but we
Homo sapiens have a remarkable capacity
for communication and innovation some of
our predecessors built fires and
gathered around they began to use tools
that were made like this there's
evidence of early use of symbols the
growth of art shared knowledge to
communicate over the centuries we have
interacted and learned from each other
communicating with language with art
with technology creating evermore
complex societies is this capacity for
culture the key to who we have become
what is it that has driven us forward
and helped us survive when others like
Homo erectus or Homo habilis died out
the skulls of our predecessors were
remarkably similar to ours so physiology
cannot have been the evolutionary key as
we seek answers from the past
neuroscience is probing the brain
looking at what mechanisms are at work
that allow us to understand each other
to mirror each other's feelings and
behavior to communicate has that social
synapse actually driven human evolution
as our brains became bigger and more
complex we may be only beginning to
understand this interaction and how it
has shaped who we are so I I was just
watching that video and I I was
wondering maybe a little show of hands
when that guy yawned how many people had
this slight push of a yawn coming yeah
well it's almost everybody and you don't
know that guy but he something he did
trigger something in your brain you felt
something you had a response and it's a
small part of the kind of connection
that we're going to be talking about
tonight and so what we're going to
examine is the question of whether this
social capacity whether it's in our
brains or in our culture is the thing
that allowed us as a species to become
so dominant our first participant is a
professor of behavioral and evolutionary
biology at the University of st. Andrews
an elected fellow of the Royal Society a
fellow of the Society of biology and the
author of Darwin's unfinished symphony
how culture made the human mind please
welcome Kevin Leyland
our next guest is a professor and chair
of anthropology at the University of
Notre Dame
his research delves into the how and why
of being human his current research
includes creativity and community in
human evolution multi-species
relationships and engaging race and
racism he is the author of two popular
science books popular science books most
recently the creative spark how
imagination made humans exceptional
please welcome Augustin Fuentes next to
join us is a professor of psychology and
the Canada Research Chair in cognition
evolution and behavior at the University
of Lethbridge she ran a long-term
project on baboons in South Africa for
12 years and currently co-directs the
Samara vervet monkey project in South
Africa she is the author of beyond the
brain how body and environment shape
animal and human minds Louise Barrett
next a professor of psychology and
director of the social cognitive and
affective neuroscience lab at Columbia
University he helped to found the social
and affective neuroscience society he is
the current president of the Society for
effective science effective that's
within a please welcome Kevin Ochsner
and finally an associate professor of
anthropology at Emory and associate
director of Emory Center for mind brain
and culture his research focuses on
Paleolithic stone tool making and human
brain evolution and the connection
between the two
let's welcome Diedrich stouts I
mentioned in the opening the word
culture in the video presented the term
capacity for culture and I think that's
a vocabulary word that we need to start
out by defining or agreeing on a
definition by the way we have a double
Kevin situation tonight the to Kevin's
raise your hands so that everybody knows
okay so when I asked Kevin you have to
guess which one I'm gonna go to but I'll
start with Kevin Leyland what do we mean
in the context in which we're discussing
it tonight of course what do we mean by
culture well I'm a biologist rather than
anthropologist so I that as a liberty to
define culture however I want so when I
use the term culture I'm I'm thinking
very broad brush terms about ability to
acquire knowledge and skills from other
individuals to express that knowledge in
our in our tools our technology our
engineering our behavior and critically
for me to build on that reservoir of
shared knowledge iteratively it sort of
fashioning ever more efficient and
diverse solutions to life's challenges
like a sharper blade or a more stable
canoe its culture is something that only
humans can have no in my definition
other animals also acquire knowledge
from from each other they also propagate
that information amongst amongst
themselves they also invent novel
refinements that behavior but there are
differences between the cultures that
other animals
and humans have so we we can talk about
animal culture but we shouldn't jump to
the conclusion that means that they have
the same thing that we have
does anybody have a dramatically
different or supplementary as an
anthropologist one thing that's really
important I agree with Kevin completely
that many things many organisms have
culture but what's fascinating about
human culture in particular is that in
addition to this sort of acquired
behavior and taught and learn and sort
of expanded behavior that can change
sort of the way which organisms interact
with the world human culture is also
built on institutions and rules and
beliefs
it does more than just sort of how we
act it actually shapes the way in which
we perceive physically physiologically
and socially the world and again
difference from animals yeah yeah
there's a difference in this sort of
intensity and extensiveness of human
culture relative to many others Louise
you were nodding yes very much I would
just add to that I think that another
part of culture that builds on what I
guess she was saying is the way in which
because we have all these cultural
artifacts and knowledge from others and
the things we make that that helps
expand our minds beyond our physical
brains that our minds are sort of leak
out into the world and so there are
things out there that you should
encompass you should extend our
cognitive system to include those so we
have much more extended lines I would
say than most other animals and Kevin
how do you use the term culture in this
conversation sure from the perspective
of psychology I think I certainly would
agree with everything everyone has said
so far but it also emphasized that human
culture is by no means unitary and
there's incredible diversity across
groups of individuals in habits customs
practices for communication of
information for the nature of
relationships how we express what's
normative for expressing our emotions to
one another that can very certainly
nationally but this kind of definition
allows us to describe cultures at the
level of families the level of any kind
of social group that can have its own
intrinsic culture and it can be going to
the Opera it can in in New York or other
cities it might entail
Deitrick have a few how you define
culture depends on who you're talking to
and what questions you're trying to
address you know and so you can have a
very broad definition of culture that
allows us to look at it across species
which is extremely useful but then you
do wind up always having this thing
where you add another word like human
culture you know so and what the one
thing that I think has been kind of in
the background of some of the
anthropological comments here is a
system of symbolic representation and
communication which brings together a
lot of these ideas about establishing
norms and even kinship structures that
go beyond the biological allows you to
have things like religions and art and
so forth and so for some anthropologists
they want to call cultural the capital C
has to have that component okay since we
have that that term is is out there now
we can use it with some familiarity it's
clear you're gonna all use it in a
slightly different way but more
importantly you're using it in an
overlapping way that I think makes sense
in this conversation tell us about how
the work that you've been doing relates
to this topic we're talking about this
humans as a as a social as is a very
successful social animal so a standard
approach for an evolutionary biologist
interested in a particular human trait
would be to sort of take a comparative
perspective let's see what other animals
are doing and that gives us a baseline
which to understand what's different or
special against humans so the approach
that I take is is no different from that
we'll study animal behavior and we're
particularly interested in the origins
of culture and one of the insights
you're coming across
I study innovation and social learning
in animals so let's take each of those
in turn
so for longest time I thought the
animals didn't really invent very much
and that they were instinct driven
creatures but as we studied animals and
and got a better understanding of their
natural behavior we were a better place
to detect departures from those from the
norm and it's become very apparent that
the animal showed creativity all the
time that many animals invent novel
behaviors
if you want you can you can find
examples of this all over YouTube it's
it's it's very prevalent so one example
that I often refer my students to is
these Japanese crows that have devised
the habit of using cars as nutcrackers
they have these nuts which are too hard
a shell for them to to break so they
just put the shells on the road cars run
them over then they go and they retrieve
the nuts and there are even some who
become so sort of traffic conscious that
they'll do this in zebra crossing so
that they can do they can retrieve the
then that's very very safely so there
are all kinds of cute examples along
these lines one of my favorites is one
of jane goodall's chimpanzees called
mike discoveries to empty kerosene cans
and that he could bang them together and
make a very loud noise and that this
would intimidate his rivals and and so
incorporated this into his dominance
display and shot up the the hierarchy
and became alpha male in record time so
so many many marvelous examples of this
that we see in nature but we can also
you know investigate innovation in a
more systematic way in the laboratory by
presenting populations of animals with
novel tasks that they have to solve and
then we look at the characteristics of
the soul were or the circumstances that
that lead to those solutions arising so
we've done a lot of work with birds
where we've investigated the spread of
novel behaviors through through bird
populations so here's an example you can
see now these are some zebra finches and
a student mind Neal jabu Gert carry out
this this task where she taught one of
these birds to flip over one of the lids
and to grab the food which is a piece of
spinach and you can see all this mayhem
is going on and we have to try and make
sense of this in some cases they're
learning from the from the demonstrating
individual we monitor the spread and
this is another example so this is what
carry out in the field
these these are bearded Capucines in
Brazil this is what
carried out my for my student Rachel
Kendall so she'll present this little
puzzle box to the to the monkeys and
this is a task that can be solved in two
ways you can see it's gonna pull on the
green handle in a second that's one way
of solving the task and there it gets
its food there's also a blue flap which
you can lift and that's another way of
solving it so we'll bait some
populations with with individuals that
they solve it one way and other
populations that solve it the other way
and we'll see whether those solutions
propagate through the population in
other cases I also got a video of some
work carry out by Lucy NAPLAN an Oxford
University on these great tips which
against a really nice study carry out by
this researcher presented these birds in
in the local woods with this little
foraging task get a mealworm and this is
a map of their social network so each
one of those little white dots
represents an individual in the
population and as the individuals light
up red that shows that they have learned
that particular behavior and you can see
it's spreading through the population
and the lines connecting individual
represent the amount of time they spend
together so you can see social learning
in front it happening in front of your
eyes here the information flow follows
the social network and the assumption is
that we have these faculties too but we
have them better more it more developed
and I think there's there's plenty of
evidence to support there but but better
in a particular sense
what's that which is that that there is
that ratcheting up of complexity that we
see in in human societies so that we can
produce a solution through a task and
then refine it and then improve it and
then get an even better solution whereas
what we see in other animals is we see
novel behavior spreads of a population
and then we'll see a different novel
behaviour spread but we rarely see
evidence that they're building on their
previous solutions team something that I
find a little hard to follow is that as
is the I think the argument being made
here that over time these
skills get passed on but that culture is
inherited in an almost evolutionary
sense but a bird a bird learning how to
to do is skill that bird dies and I
would say well doesn't its knowledge of
that skill die with it and it's not
passed on what so what's his argument
about culture being inherited so let's
even take that bird example and then
given a human example so what you're
really seeing that trait that skill as
we just saw is in the culture is in the
social group it's there as we said
earlier in part of the extended group
well if the entire group dies and you're
a great tit that behavior is dead for
that population right if every
practitioner but that capacity is part
of the social interaction in the
landscape in humans we take that as as
Kevin just said we ratcheted up another
level for example we don't just sort of
learn to acquire a behavior I know how
to screw the lid off of a bottle right
but then we imbue that behavior with all
sorts of symbolic meaning of importance
so not only do I unscrew the the bottle
but I if it's a particular bottle I pour
it into a glass and I share it and we
raise it we drink it have a really good
time those kinds of interactions the
meaning the sharing the acquiring not
just through learning but through social
interactions and interfaces of the
meaning of the behaviors is actually
something characteristically human but
this kind of sharing of information not
in an evolutionary sense such that it
impacts the body and the organisms is
common for many many many societies of
animals in addition to humans
the idea that evolution is just about
mating and dying
that's very antiquated and actually a
misrepresentation it's not what Darwin
said and it's not what we understand as
evolutionary biology can I repeat back
what I think I've heard you say is that
the culture that create organisms create
animals create are huge human animals
create becomes what part of that
environment that then shapes the genetic
reaction to the environment and the
behavior of the feedback reaction the
brain the way in which we perceive and
feel the world is shaped by the ways in
which we push into the world and it
pushes back to us so
that relationship that mutual mutability
between organisms and their environment
is actually how evolutionary processes
move I want to go to an experimental
moment can you bring out your your your
box so tell us what this is about well
as we've discussed one of the
distinctive things about human cultures
is capacity to ratchet up in complexity
over time and we needed a experimental
way to mimic that that we could present
to to animals so this is a simulated
cumulative culture puzzle box it can be
solved at three different levels to
yield ever more desirable rewards so the
simplest level is you slide the door to
one side and this reveals a chute well
you get a low grade reward so if you're
a chimpanzee or a capuchin monkey you
might get a piece of carrot and then you
can build on that you can refine that if
you like by pressing down this this
button here and you can slide it further
and that will give you a higher grade
reward it might be a piece of apple and
then there's this knob at the end which
if you turn you can slide the door
further still and that would give the
highest grade reward which would be a
great so these are increasingly
desirable to her to a non-human primate
there are two sides to this so
potentially two individuals can interact
with it at the same time so we presented
this this experimental apparatus to
small groups of nursery school children
aged 4 to 5 to of capuchin monkeys and
groups of chimpanzees and the idea was
to see what were they capable of solving
this were they capable this kind of
simulated cumulative culture and if not
to try and work out why not what would
the we thought it's quite likely the
children would be able to solve this so
what would the children be doing
differently and sure enough as we
anticipated the children solve this task
very easily they helped each other they
we had multiple children in multiple
groups solving the task at the highest
level so the solutions spread through
their groups whereas you might get the
odd chimpanzee or capuchin monkey that
solved the task at a higher level but
those solutions never spread so we
didn't see evidence for that community
of cultural learning so we then asked
able to say what was it that the
children were doing different
we found they were teaching each other
they were pointing each other and saying
press this here you turn this here that
teaching was largely through verbal
instruction and the communication that
the children engaged in enhance the
performance of the recipient whereas the
other two species engaged in plenty of
communication we didn't do anything for
the recipients performance they the turn
was sit down and they never take each
other's actions they produce matching
manipulations of the box
whereas very little matching in the
other two species kind of and the
children help each other there were many
many acts of sort of spontaneous
pro-sociality whether it even they'd
even give their retrieved rewards to
other children which I think shows that
they they understood that the other
children shared their intentions and
goals it's all the way from Scotland I
did and it's extremely heavy yeah I
don't want to think what United Airlines
made of it but what it demonstrates is
that these high fidelity information
transmission mechanisms are critical to
this capacity and the Scottish children
are really smart
augustin as the anthropologists on the
panel you have written that human
creativity is the thing that allows us
to look at what is and talk about what
it could be and then in the next
sentence you wrote and we're hardwired
for this what are you saying there well
what I really think given years of
looking at humans and other primates
doing this broad what we think of in a
biological approach comparing what
humans do can do and what other
organisms doing can do and not asking
how are humans better but asking what
does it look like what are the
commonalities and the differences and
let me give you an example that I think
highlights where I think this creativity
comes in I was watching a group of
monkeys in Bali and in this group there
was just one female who never had
offspring and to sort of be part of this
group you have to have offspring right
and so whenever we would be sitting
she'd always be separate from the group
and so I'd be sitting there taking some
data and I'd look watch around and she'd
be about 10 meters from me writing I'd
look over she'd be about 5 meters from
me sort of look around to be about 2
meters from me and
and I'd feel this sort of warmth on my
thigh she would just sit there and sort
of lean against me like this she was she
needed social interaction as a prime it
as a social organism and she found a
very socially creative way to do it so
that's something that we share in common
to other primates but we on the other
hand when we need these interactions we
do other things we build houses we build
fences we see other people as our kin
and to find other people as something
completely different and we do so
unbelievably creatively we create
symbols and meaning all of this stuff we
imagine worlds and impose those on the
material in front of us and I'm very
interested in how that happens we have
that capacity we talk about the social
brain this capacity to imagine the world
and to make those imaginings concrete
reality is very impressive and how do we
do it that's a very good question I
think a lot of the ways we can do it in
much of what we'll be talking about is
this incredible capacity for
collaboration and cooperation for
getting together this notion of sharing
information and then finding ways to
work that information together as a
group to develop new things this is what
makes humans amazing and what makes us
do incredibly good things and gives us
the capacity to horrendously bad things
your your work has had this very
specific relationship to culture and in
terms of communication talk about that a
little bit so I think what's really
important here is understanding not just
linguistic communication but meaning
dense meaning that humans have so for
example we don't just sort of show
information or do a behavior
we also imbue that with symbolic meaning
so later we'll talk a little bit about
some of the early art that's out there
these niches okay so there are 80,000
120,000 years ago if you look here these
are pieces of ochre a little bit of red
clay like material that 80,000 years ago
in South Africa someone or a group of
people took and made these lines in and
made the lines and this little piece of
okra is about this big and they had even
smaller ones that that that they carved
little lines into and we find them in
these places where they're making very
complicated tools very fascinating
functional material items but then why
are they doing this what's going on here
why little hash marks in Red Rocks it's
not just that these marks were
made eighty thousand one hundred twenty
thousand two hundred thousand years ago
it's that they had meaning to the people
making them and they used this as a way
to communicate something about
themselves or something about the others
without being there without a time
machine we don't know what that meaning
was here we see some other examples as
well but we know that they were taking
the material world
imagining imbuing it with some meaning
and then sharing that with one another
and that's a little bit different than a
group of tits showing how to get some
food right it's actually changing the
way in which we perceived this is a
wonderful example this is a piece of
okra that's this big it's very hard to
even see but they spent hours probably
gauging these really little straight
lines there's three or four straight
lines another line down it I have no
idea why they did that but they did it
and they knew why they did it did
they're doing that grow our brains our
brains are the same size now as they
were that maybe even Mars are a little
smaller in some cases but what's amazing
is it probably grew the way in which our
brains are changed the way in which our
brains perceive the world and perceived
one another by imposing meaning on to
the world we started the shift the way
our brains interpret perceive and engage
the world and movies that's the sense in
which we mean culture moving on that
this this this imbuing of meaning in
this communication in this connectedness
is that I think what happens with human
children you're born into a world that's
full of meaning already you know if you
just think about how much you can pick
up just from everyday experience so we
live in houses and this is a room you
eat in and this is a room you sleep in
right and you don't have to be taught
that it's just you participate in your
culture you're learning all the time
you're picking up these kinds of things
because most of its out there there's a
lot of material culture out there which
is allowing you to learn how to
participate and take part in your
culture so I mean if you look at I mean
Halloween in in North America is a very
big thing and you just see all these
little kids dressed up as Princess Leia
or you know whoever and and some of them
are too tiny to even know why they're
doing it or who they are you know it's
for their parents and they're very proud
but the child is participating in her
culture and over time that public
display will become internalized or
understand why is she's participating
what the meaning the deep deeper meaning
of Princess Leia is and it's so
important to her dad that she dresses up
like that
and I think that's that's the kind of
thing that the Augustine's getting at
that it's through this you participate
in your culture and through that
participation you can to absorb your
culture into you and not just the
culture you're born in but your entire
cultural history yeah and I mean it's
what this what Kevin would call niche
construction which is the idea that we
engineer our own environments and those
things allow us and that's to feedback
and as you were saying like you know
that it changes the way natural
selection acts on genes so we kind of
select for our own genetic you know
evolution Louise how does your work shed
light again on how we do it well I mean
the the again I work on on primates and
humans and when you spend all day long
out with monkeys what what you notice is
that they don't have days of the week
they don't have time of day you suddenly
realize that there's a different way of
being and that work that's what really
got me interested in is like when you
have a non linguistic animal these are
my vervet monkeys here that we that we
study when you're a non linguistic
animal if you don't see something happen
it might as well never have happened you
you know you have no means of
transmitting that information so it's
interesting to like look at a non human
society and non linguistic society and
look at how their sociality functions
and then come back into the human world
and then you'll all the things that that
Augustine was saying are thrown into
this very very sharp relief that we have
things like marriage and money and they
are only things that exist because we
all agree they do you know these pieces
of paper in themselves don't have any
meaning and so were you primarily drawn
to this study because you were primarily
interested in learning about humans or
were you primarily interested in
learning about the primates I began as
an ecologist and I was a plant ecologist
there wasn't even an ammonite I got I
did a course in my third year University
on primate behavior and I was that just
who just like something clicked and I
was really fascinated by and I also was
very interested to go to Africa I'd
always wanted to go to Africa
so in a kind of series of accidents I
got the chance to go and study monkeys
in Uganda and for my PhD but I kind of
do accidentally and then so I I was a
real and I was an animal behaviorist I
was interesting animals for their own
sake and I still am but as a consequence
of going out every day and living a
company and living a completely
different kind of life having an seeing
a completely different way of being it
kind of when you come back into the
human world do you realize how like
deeply weird
it is like humans are weird and that's
what that's what really got me
interested in finding out more about why
humans are weird but humans are weird
but is that our secret strength power
yeah I think I think that deep weirdness
is we don't see it we don't see it yeah
because we swim in the water it's big
Kevin tell us about how your work
relates to the topic we're talking about
tonight sure so I work in an area that's
the intersection some social psychology
and neuroscience known as social
neuroscience and the big interest of
this field is in trying to understand
how the brain that we have today gives
rise to all the complexities of culture
social interaction that we take for
granted moment to moment and that formed
the basis of all of our social
relationships do you mean them in very
small ways the little one-to-one react
interaction is yes for sure
so the primary tool we use for doing
this is functional brain imaging so if
any of you've ever had an MRI we use
that basic kind of tool where you have
to try to figure out a way to study
social interaction with people that are
lying on a flat bed not moving on their
back this is a little bit difficult but
luckily we had this incredible capacity
for creativity and imagination and so
you can show movies and ask people to
simulate social interactions or actually
have them play interactive games through
a computer that captured many isn't
quite in the MRI machine in there
watching movies and absolutely sure you
may not want them to move too much
because it's a little bit like one of
those old-time cameras where you leave
the shutter open and if people were to
move it would just be blurred yeah
that's kind of like what fMRI is right
now we're taking pictures of we're sort
of mapping the activity of the brain
every second or two
seconds and if you move too much it gets
a blurry picture and and to what degree
are you trying to map track trace social
interactions I think my lab does not and
many other labs try to do that around
the world the different complex brain
systems that give rise to the kinds of
behaviors that you're seeing Illustrated
on the monitor right now where could be
something as simple as two people
passing by greeting each other on the
street it turns out it's a whole
symphony of brain systems like look
different you can imagine each part of
your brain is part of a sort of like
there's the woodwind area the brass area
and they're each playing different kinds
of notes that are effective in the
emotional sense or social and the way in
which they all combine is the kind of
music of our behavior and the way we
interact with one another I mean I
happen to know from having worked on the
topic of autism for a long time that
even an operation for a child who has
profound impairment from art for autism
being taught how to get into an elevator
and ride it it's very very complicated
including just the fact that when you
walk into the elevator you turn around
and face the door and that you separate
that you form you separate an equal
amount of space from everybody else in
the elevator because they're all doing
the same thing and nobody ever teaches
us to do that we just sort of have
figured it out through some sort of
subtle to me invisible
social signaling we do try to study that
kind of complex social interaction so
how we might recognize each other's
facial expressions or how I might read
subtle changes in your body language
your tone of voice the way you look at
me if I'm not standing quite the right
way in the elevator like if I stand too
close to you yeah or if I'm a close
talker the kind of hmm the way in which
you move subtly backward as I inch
closer to continue being a close talker
we do try to study those kinds of things
and what brain systems are important for
that sense of I need to avoid this guy
in the future because I don't want his
breath in my face all the time
it's very interesting you mentioned
autism because one of the arguments is
that children and people with autism
they lack her sort of theory of mind
they lack an understanding of how to
take another person's
perspective and the same is true of
monkeys they don't have much in the way
of their they can't you know but they
don't behave like autistic individuals
they don't play about people with autism
they behave they're very socially adept
they're very good at picking up cues
from others all the things you were
talking about in terms of the monkey
quill have an elevator behavior so all
these kinds of facial signals and so
what I mean is that how much of those we
use in our everyday life and how they
kind of oil the wheels of these bigger
forms of cooperation that we engage in
so how do you build up to human society
from from what you have in in monkey
society are you reaching any preliminary
conclusions or some guesses hunches that
you're working towards um I think these
kind of these sort of emotional empathic
connections we have a very important I
think we use them far more than we than
we think we do I mean there's there's
these are very old findings from from
you know ethology but you know there's
this kind of thing when you see people
at a distance and you're walking down a
corridor and you just kind of you know
your knowledge and you just raise your
eyebrows you go hi and then if you
notice like you you don't really you
can't even look at each other again -
you're much closer right you you
actually the way if you want to freak
someone out in any way you want as you
screech them and you acknowledge them
with your eyebrow flash then just keep
looking at them intently as you walk
through and closer and closer it will
they will feel very uncomfortable and
and the other things like if you want an
empty seat next to you on a train or a
bus you know every once I put my bag on
there put my coat on there you know
that'll keep everyone away as though
some people aren't going to say could
you move that or is anyone sitting there
the way to sit on your own in any social
situation like that is to keep the seat
entirely empty and then as soon as
someone gets on catch their eye and Pat
the seat next to you you'll that that is
the key that's the one thing I ever
learned from psychologists usually yeah
and so those are the sorts of things
that you see in monkeys right so how do
we you know we use those all the time
how do they help us do these other
things are these the things that that
the oil the wheels and help these more
complex forms of cooperation run
smoothly
Deitrick you you're really coming from
in a sense left field with the the thing
that you are so good at
which is making stone tools the way that
the way that the ancients did have you
get into the stone tool making business
well I mean I think I think I've always
been interested in just how the mind
works the nature of human thought you
know and I had no idea what you needed
to do to study that when I went to
college and maybe philosophy or
something and I had a professor who was
a good one and he told me oh you should
take some anthropology classes and I
took an archaeology class and one of the
lectures was introducing the topic of
stone tools and they say well you know
here we have a stone tool that was
shaped by somebody you know 200 thousand
years ago and you can see each little
piece that's been removed records a
specific action and a choice that this
individual made 200 thousand years ago
we can have a window on their mind and
their decision making process and what
they were thinking and I said well you
know we need to study this if we
actually want it obviously our modern
mind came to revolutionary processes
from the past but how are we going to
get evidence of that and and it seems to
me that this was a somewhat
underutilized for that kind of question
source of information and so I say well
well what can we learn from the
archaeological record and fortunately at
that point I didn't know how difficult
it was to learn anything from little
bits of broken rod but if you study
stone tools as an archaeologist one
thing that many of us believe you should
do is know something about how to make
them you know so many people do acquire
at least a little bit of skill and some
take it to very high levels I for it
I've always remained with very primitive
stone tools yeah so but if you want to
study later periods of prehistory you
actually have to have a stand of time to
learn the things that they did which
were very sophisticated so I stay with
you know kind of Homo erectus level
stuff myself the really interesting
thing about your work is what you think
it tells you about what's going on in
the brain while the work is being done
so let's let's have you show a little
bit first how it works and then talk
about what you think is going on in the
brain and why that matters to this
conversation okay sure yeah well I
happen to have brought a hundred pounds
of rock with me
yeah in case you are going to ask social
part of the show so what I can show you
is something I've been working on a bit
which is how to make a later issue lien
hand axe so this is the kind of tool
that you might find from about 500,000
years ago Homo heidelbergensis it's made
to be used in your hands so it's got a
bit of weight behind it but it has a
nice sharp cutting edge on it and it's
characteristically a symmetrical and
quite thin in cross-section which gives
you a lot of cutting edge for the amount
of weight that you have to carry around
so you in order to get this you start
with a piece of Flint like this one and
what you'll maybe immediately notice is
it doesn't have any edges on it and it's
also really thick and heavy and so the
trick is I'm going to have to first
impose an edge around it so that I have
the right angles to shoot flakes that
this is broken pieces of rock we call
them flakes that go more than halfway
across the surface so it can actually
reduce the thickness of this piece and
so to start off I'll choose an
appropriate hammer stone a fairly large
one to do what we call opening the core
and I'm just trying to establish flint
knapping is a lot about it will make a
lot about edges right alright so I'm
going to try to establish an acute angle
that I can use alright and so I've by
taking off a piece now I've got an acute
angle I can flip it over and go in the
other direction and start shooting
flakes can you go you hope just hold it
up for a second for the camera to catch
it so that and turn it around a little
bit just so people can see what progress
you've made and just hold there for a
second alright so I just removed a
couple flakes there and you see that
where this is 90 degree angles and flat
now we have acute angles you can start
to work with is the idea anyway and so I
would move through the piece maybe
breaking off too much there
right and do this back and forth until
it starts doing you can already see it
starting to assume a little bit more of
the kind of shape you might want right
what so sorry there you can see so
anyway I would do that for a while and
then suddenly it would look like this
and so you can see in this this piece is
that it has the angles on the edge all
the way around it and what I want to do
is regularize that and then start
thinning it so I actually start doing
some very more meticulous types of
modifications of the edge to establish
just the right kind of geometric
relationships to remove the flicks that
I want to have come off and then I'll
also use a different kind of a hammer no
longer the big you know hard rock but
something this is a moose antler
actually and this initiates a different
kind of fracture by causing tension and
literally tearing flakes off if it works
you can see the flakes that are coming
off now are thinner sorry trying to get
it on camera here and and they are
starting to invade into the piece so let
me see if I can get off one good
thinning flake as a demonstration this
is something we call platform
preparation and if you want to think
about it it means that you have to sort
of stop what you're doing and do
something else for a while
it seems in a way to be taking you away
from your goal so you kind of have a
little sub operation that you do in the
midst of something else guys so if you
put it back on you can see that these
flakes are now thinner and they're
moving into the center or taking off
pieces towards the middle and starting
to thin it down a little bit do you
enjoy doing this yes it's a lot of fun
so let's get to what it means
yeah so you had students doing this and
you have you were doing brain imaging
yeah now again these you were not able
to put them inside an MRI well sure you
can do the show the videos right so a
lot of your work relies on this idea as
well that we use some of the same
systems to understand observed actions
that we do to actually execute them this
is a foundation of some forms of social
cognition all right so we can see how
what the brain systems that people use
to understand what they're seeing when
they're in the MRI but we can also use a
different technique which is positron
emission tomography which use was like
cutting-edge in the early 90s or
something if you want to use it much
anymore but that involves a radiological
tracer that's injected and it is taken
up in the brain like glucose over a
great student we get injected in the
foot yeah and it hurt yeah yeah so the
reason yeah the foot was apparently very
difficult and the reason why we did that
was so that wouldn't mess with their
arms while they were doing the
flintknapping
and so you've got a guy with like a tube
in his foot and he's betting in a rock
and you're tracing his brain okay yeah
well they yeah you know they put a port
in his foot and I took it off so it
wasn't it wasn't that that bad but yeah
so you could actually do it and we got
images that what did you learn well what
the the the goal was to sort of map out
the basic systems that are involved but
also then to compare different
technologies because we have an
evolutionary sequence in the archeology
of what we think are more and less
complicated types of stone tools and we
wanted to see as these tools became more
sophisticated where exactly is the brain
sort of feeling the pinch of these
increased demands you know and so we
would compare them and the results
indicated in some cognitive control type
areas which is this sort of whereas the
early Stone tool-making was very
demanding of perceptual motor
coordination you know think like sport
or crafts or something like that the
making the hand axe required more what
we call top-down
and control kind of activity and so that
was a contrast that we made
interestingly enough some of these
cognitive control regions are relevant
to some processes that are also relevant
for human language so there's an
argument to be made that early stone
tool-making could have helped to lay the
foundations for what later evolved into
human language was doing the work a
social activity was somebody being
taught by somebody else because I mean
there's a lot of people in the room here
but you could have definitely done that
by yourself up here on this stage
although which would have been strange
but but was it a social activity in
itself
yeah well Kevin participated in an
experiment along these lines but it's
it's hard to know for sure exactly how
things were learned in the past all
right so I did I was lucky enough to do
some ethnography in 1999 in New Guinea
with some modern stone and tool makers
there I know and I showed up and I
wanted to record their behavior and one
of the first things a scientist like
okay I want you to be isolated over here
so I can study you and they say no way
we don't do it we always do this
together this is something we do as a
community and it has meaning for us it
is part of my identity and you know
you're coming at it the wrong way
because I'm sort of imposing this idea
that oh technology is this purely
non-social functional thing that we do
over there you know and that's not how
they saw it I suspect that's more
accurate to how things were in
prehistory than sort of our modernist
ideas about the difference between
society and technology but it's hard to
know exactly what teaching was required
so I can say that by the time they're
doing something like this they're doing
a technique that is quite difficult for
us to communicate to others without some
intentional teaching however it is
possible for you to discover this
yourself you know in fact of course as
archaeologists that's what we spend a
lot of years doing is rediscovering
these techniques so it's possible but it
seems improbable after a certain point
how far you going as a careful scientist
in terms of your assertion that this
that this tool making impact on the
development of the brains of the people
who did it got
talking also I'm going far enough to say
that I would really like to do more
research and we are but I think you know
it's a it's important to appreciate that
this is not just the functional imaging
which people are maybe more familiar
with but also structural imaging so that
we can look at the changes that
physically happen for instance to white
matter tracks and in the brain as you're
trained in these techniques and it is
the same regions that become
functionally active so it's not only
that you're doing it and thinking it but
practicing it changes your brain and
that leads to this argument about how
cultural inheritance can feed back with
biology to create evolutionary change
yeah I mean I was gonna bring that
question back to to Kevin and where
would you go with that Todd so we've
been interested in that in that feedback
loop and and one thing that led us to
starting the wise lines is if you look
at humans we see we're very creative we
see the we're very culturally reliant we
see we also have large brains and you
know is that just coincidence or did one
cause the other is that that feedback
going on one way we could address that
would would be to look at patterns of
innovation and social learning in other
animals and see whether they Co vary
with brain size so we looked across
primates we compiled data banks of rates
of innovation for different species of
primates rates of social learning for
different species of primates and then
plotted those against each other and we
found sure enough yes
big brain species of primates are more
innovative innovative they they invent
more new behavior they copy each other
more than do small brain two species of
primates and this led us to endorse the
argument that this was no coincidence
that that natural selection might be
favoring innovative nursing might be
favoring more efficient more accurate
forms of copying and this would drive a
feedback loop that would would favor
those structures or capabilities in the
brain
the perceptual systems computational
capabilities the ability to take in the
perceptual inputs of others and and
transform them into them that matching
motor outputs so these kind of
capabilities would be favored in a
feedback loop that would only
incidentally be manifested in bigger
brains but with wood feedback to further
enhance the accuracy and efficiency of
copy and we inferred that if that were
the case then since a lot of the novel
innovations that we're seeing in our
primates that socially transmitted
behaviors that we're seeing are foraging
behaviors they often involve tools they
often involve animals extracting foods
from substrates in complex ways that we
should see rates of social learning and
innovation correlated across primates
with rates of tool use rates of
extractive foraging breadth of their
diets and other measures of the
complexity of their behavior even longer
lives and again when we looked at this
we compiled databases for all of these
things we look to see do these things
all go together we found indeed they did
and and I mean so much so you could
actually you can actually do a factor
analysis which allows us to kind of
partition the variance and all of these
different measures and the bulk of the
variance is aligned along a single
dimension which you can think of as as
intelligence and you know you plot that
against brain size you've got a positive
relationship and and you can also plot
that you can you can put that into a
family tree for non-human primates and
you see evidence for convergent
evolution that's repeated evolution for
higher intelligence in in four distinct
primate groups the Capucines the macaque
the baboons and the great apes which are
precisely those species which are
renowned for their social learning and
innovation so this really fits the
argument that social and innovation is
driving brain evolution and the
evolution of complex behavior I want to
invite Louise to add something you were
talking about before we came on that you
don't quite agree with the idea that the
brain is should that what we referred to
as the brain is solely the organ
inside our skull well the mind the mind
is not the brain is inside your skull
okay if you don't you don't want that
leaking so so well I mean one of the
reasons I got interested in some very
good lines tonight one of the reasons I
got interested in in the brain itself is
because there are many more things with
very small brains or no brain at all on
this planet than things is very big
brains and so it's like how come big
brains are quite rare and how come there
are so many successful organisms who do
show quite flexible behavior with very
tiny brain so that's what that's where I
got interested and then once you do that
you realize well brains are part of a
larger system they're embedded in a body
which is embedded in an environment and
so all of those things together
constitute the cognitive system or they
constitute the mind so so everything you
have to take all of those things into
account
so I find it I always find it very
interesting when neuroscientists thought
ago the brain does this and the brain
does that so it's as though it's not
part of the person as that you know and
it's always like your brain that I
literally went to a talk once it's very
famous neuroscience Christopher and he
said your brain knows more about this
than you do and it's like reading you're
like hang on
do you know me like hang on but I am my
brain you just said I was my brain and
now it doesn't know it knows more than I
so I find those kinds of things get you
know you get very into this kind of
slightly do a list view of things and
it's just a way of bringing the brain
and the body and the world back together
again so that we understand because
because I mean what what what Duke is
doing there is action it's like doing
stuff to the world it's like breaking
thing you know that's what you see when
you watch baboons when you watch
capuchin monkeys they're trying to break
the world see they're very destructive
in various many ways and I but I think
that's how they learn so we had a we had
a we bought a quad for the quad bike for
our project and we were so proud of him
we bought a net for her and her gloves
and goggles and all these things and
then we left it parked out of the way we
thought nobody
and then we came back and the baboons
had found it and the goggles were gone
and the netting with this thing was
stripped right there
we've been all over it and taken a you
know just to kind of understand the what
just to see how they could understand
the world they they kind of try and pull
it upon break-in I think that's what we
do too and I think that's the origins of
our intelligence the amazing thing that
part of that is that shared primate
reality but Dietrich if you can hold up
the large sort of rock the larger one
and the final sort of hand acts so what
we do as humans this back to our
beginning of our conversation and
culture what we do as humans we might
break part of the world but we imagined
inside that rock this other tool this
other way of doing something so part of
this culture that yes you can put it
down this this part of the culture that
we're talking about we talk about human
culture many things have culture but our
capacity to look at that whole rock and
to have a social context of history a
knowledge a shared ideology that allows
us to see inside that rock is this other
tool this other thing that is
particularly humans and it's
particularly interesting it is one more
thing I want to ask you is you know like
with sculpt to say oh the statue is just
in there I just had to like no is that
what happens with is there when you get
a core does the core somehow also
dictate how you approach the thing in
the final project no not really
yeah only in the broadest terms you like
well this is gonna be a problem but but
you actually have a bunch of rules of
thumb in the production process you go
through and sort of like little targets
along the way it's like well I needed to
you know get the edges all like this and
then I look at it again and see where I
am and sort of sort of reassess like
that and but I think that you know we're
sort of dancing around these these
issues of meaning and representation and
symbolism and you know we on the one
hand we're having this discussion about
how we can talk about culture and
learning and other animals but then we
want to make these dichotomous things
between what but you know when they do
these foraging behaviors that they learn
it's not meaningful in the same way as
human art is or anything I'm just
interested just I don't have answers but
to probe that in the archaeological
record you know and is it really
different you know these artistic
objects that you showed August in a very
you know
vaca t'v to us because we don't know why
they did it we call it non-functional
but of course they had a function
it was a perhaps a social communicative
function and is that really different
neroli in terms of evolved neural
substrates from the functions just
because one of them supports harvesting
calories and the other supports your
interactions these are the questions
that we need to ask to understand how
these things you fall is there a social
brain apart from general intelligence in
your opinions Kevin so I think at some
level the entire brain is social because
it's almost banal to say that we're
using our capacity for sight audition
and so on at every moment but at the
same time there are particular brain
systems that are really critical for
knowing whether you're someone that's a
friend or a foe I should approach or I
should avoid for reading subtle
nonverbal cues for being able to subtly
mimic and mirror your behavior you were
referencing that earlier and then for
going beyond just the simple facial
expression that you've got so a smile
may seem like the most straightforward
an obvious thing for us to interpret but
it really depends on the context in
which you see someone else smiling so if
you're on a used-car lot and the
used-car salesman comes up with a big
smile on their face and holds out their
hand he's probably not wanting to be
your friend
he's probably wanting to manipulate the
impression that you form of him and
trying to sell you something and we're
really good at drawing that inference at
a high level and that's a really
abstract kind of symbolic inference
where we have language for personality
and feeling States like somebody's
gregarious or manipulative or deceptive
and so on and that symbolic terminology
is really useful for us so if you
imagine the example that Louise just
gave about it's also thinking you don't
live in New York because lots of these
behaviors you see at some point in New
York
you know like walking down the street
and having somebody just stare at you as
you walk by or having people check you
out mm-hmm so that's what you're wearing
today you get that yes and in New York
you learn to just accept and allow that
kind of behavior and all it's like
that's normative here
it's okay whatever people are doing you
could run naked through Times Square and
people go okay so that's happening today
all right I gotta get to work
so but trying to infer the intentions
like why was somebody doing that why is
this person padding the seat next to me
that requires an unbelievable set of
social skills there's a kind of social
calculus that goes into it
so while culture may prescribe all kinds
of norms for behavior that we in part
learn implicitly by observing the
behaviors of others and having them
shape and reinforce our behavior by
telling us no no no you can't do that
right now as a child you need to do this
other thing as adults we try to reuse
the infirmities we implicitly use the
social norms to try to decide whether or
not the behavior another person's
engaging in is something about them or
something about the social norm so if
I'm just sitting there quietly on the
subway it doesn't tell me that much
about that person but if they're padding
the seat and smiling at everybody as
they walk by it's probably something
unusual about that person because
they're engaging in a socially non
normative behavior and our capacity for
intelligence that isn't social is itself
something difficult to define is it raw
processing speed the ability the whole
should we be making a distinction
between calculating intelligence and the
intelligent being intelligent enough to
know that the walk person walking
towards you as a threat are those two
different kinds of intelligence or do we
even know that well there are certainly
some people who think they're
qualitatively different
I think we're bringing to bear all of
these different skills all the time and
social interaction so if I'm in a
complex business negotiation with you
and I'm trying to infer your intention
I'm probably using my capacity to hold
information in what's called working
memory which is often part of
intelligence tests that are not supposed
to be not social
but I'm using the capacity to try to
remember all the things that you've done
in the context of this interaction to
try to bring to mind what I know about
your personality what I know about your
history what are your goals likely to be
with respect to me are you trying to
deceive me right now are you as genuine
as you appear to be and so on all of
that requires a complex set of skills
some of which are social reading the
nonverbal cues and so on but some of
which are probably not necessarily
social that we'd use to remember phone
numbers or solve math problems at the
same time
and loosely speaking there are brain
networks that are roughly more involved
in one of those behaviors than another
but as soon as you start poking around
you'll find that virtually every brain
system is engaged in multiple different
kinds of behaviors Augustine you were
noting a lot during that yeah I think
it's really important in this is to we
try so hard to say well this kind of
intelligence like this is for math and
this is for finding a sexual partner and
this is for finding a best friend that's
really problematic because it is that
combination of everything that is so
powerful there's this idea of symbol and
connection in the sociality right the
whole idea that for us sometimes patting
the the chair next to us as an example
might freak someone out but to someone
else who might say wow hey I want to go
sit next to her so I'm gonna move over
here you know talk at that and so our
capacity to navigate these landscapes
these unbelievably complex Nets we do
this every day we stand in lines right
we don't get hit by cars on average here
in New York but sometimes but we
negotiate all these things deploying all
of these capacities simultaneously and
so it's really interesting from a lot of
the work that everyone here is doing is
the amazing capacity we have to be doing
multiple things simultaneously but that
they all center around the social
parallel with what you're just talking
about not separating not drawing these
lines between theoretical kinds of
intelligence is the fact that the five
of you represent almost completely
supposedly non-overlapping academic
disciplines we've got a biologist kind
of anthropologist we've got a couple of
psychologists and I'm wondering and the
paleontologists are are we these
divisions do they make sense in your
notes now
which what should go into disciplinarian
oh yeah I think the the capacity yeah
that I mean knowledge the world is not
divided up into like anther departments
in biology and political science the
world is out there we for some reason
think the world works that way that's
why a lot of students get bored in
college if we're so smart and so social
why do we have war because we're so
smart and so social one of the
incredible things we've been talking
about all this collaboration all this
working together thinking about affect
interpreting other's behavior creating
symbol imbuing meaning into things
one of the amazing things that humans
can do is cooperate kevin's example just
saw us that right down to the core
humans cooperate incredibly well but in
our evolutionary history especially the
last couple hundred thousand years
especially the last ten thousand years
we see increasing sort of patterns of
inequality between groups increasing
ability to hold on to resources where
other groups don't have resources we've
set a stage where conflict pays off in
ways that didn't use to and we have this
incredible capacity for cooperation and
to make symbol so if you think about all
this our ability to be peaceful to work
together to collaborate also makes us
incredibly good at something horrible
war the ability to get together to care
for one another to cooperate with the
intention of getting something over
there our ability to think symbolically
to dehumanize to call that other group
something less than human and to work
together to take what that other group
has is all from the same capacity but
the landscape of human evolution has
changed and we see this translated into
kind of ferociousness a kind of
potential for incredible cruelty but
that downside is also the upside right
there's I think in case even right today
where there's a lot of problems in in
many societies and ours in particular
with not understanding thinking about
what science can contribute what
understanding the world what testable
reliable methodological assessment of
the world around us tells us and then
using that information we have that
capacity and there are a lot of us a few
people might not
do that but there are more of us who
want to do that and who have the power
to cooperate to work together to make
change then there are who don't want to
do that and I think that's potentially
optimistic anybody else optimistic based
on your work yeah just generally I'm
optimistic but I think I one of the
things I think that's interesting is we
now have named this new epoch you know
the Anthropocene we've come up with this
name because we're the largest
geological force on it so now we're in
this Anthropocene epoch which we govern
things like the climate which has never
happened before in the history of Earth
and I think part of why that makes me
optimistic is what I think part of the
problem is often with things like trying
to get to grips and things like climate
changes where you often see ourselves as
standing apart from nature that we
either it's there you know it's wild and
we have to tame it or we have to control
it or you know this or it's something
delicate that we have to preserve and
but we are part of nature we're in the
world and I think if we had greater
understanding of that maybe that would
help us realize that we have to protect
all of it to protect ourselves it's in
our own interest to do it and maybe
something like the Anthropocene
generates more of a an understanding of
that that we are not we don't stand up
outside of nature and and culture is our
nature do you know what I mean cultures
not let me like ever take one so as we
wrap up yeah I had two thoughts so one
is it might help to remember that
capacities for empathy and compassion
aren't gendered if there's an
interesting lesson from the history of
neuroscience research where for a long
time in non-human models of in
biomedical research only males were
studied or primarily males were studied
because the estrus cycle the menstrual
cycle complicated things too much and so
the idea that you may have learned an
introductory psychology class that we
have the fight-or-flight response when
stressed turns out to be guys and that
there's a psychologist named Shelly
Taylor who wrote a great book called the
taming instinct which is all about how
when you look at the response to stress
and threat in females it's more
and to Mike in and try to befriend the
person who wants to have a conflict with
me and I think that might be an
interesting lesson for modern times
you've been great thank you so much
thank you everybody else bye-bye